[Applause]
what a crowd what
a thank
you well what
what what post elction enthusiasm we're
showing in here and I think I know why
that you know Republicans killed it on
Tuesday finally white men are going to
get a seat at the table ladies and
gentlemen it's been a long time
coming oh what a blood bath for
Democrats on Tuesday I've not seen
liberals this down since kale went on a
season
I I turned on MSN NBC the other day uh
Chris Matthews was just stumbling around
with a bottle of whiskey in his
hand singing Danny Boy I I it's
sad
at at the White House a lunatic jumped
the fence trying to get
out it's
it's Anthony Weiner
today tweeted a picture of his penis but
it was you
[Music]
know he was it was a
sad but it's true I mean all you had to
do to win on Tuesday in this country was
have an R next year name Republicans
elected anybody who was a republic they
elected I'm not kidding about this a
black woman to Congress from
Utah she is the first Republican black
woman in Congress and she is a Mormon
which is
progress uh Mormons didn't admit blacks
until the 70s and Republicans didn't
admit them until Tuesday so it's it's a
very good
sign one of the
few now I'm telling you even the
Republicans who seemed completely
unelectable because they up so
badly in their District of their state
got elected Michael Grim the we had him
in our sweet 16 for FPA District the
meat head from Staten Island who is
going to jail he's under 20 counts of
indictment for fraud he
won Sam Brownback that governor in
Kansas who singlehandedly ruined the
entire economy of the St he won Joanie
erns the crazy lady from Iowa you
remember the one with all her ads were
about I used to cast rate hogs on the
firm well you know Michelle Bachmann is
leaving Congress so you
know Joanie erns stepping right in this
is what the evangelicals always say
right when the good Lord closes one door
in an insane
asylum he opens a window in the nut
housee and I
think but uh yeah when Jonie erns made
her victory speech there in Iowa she
said she's going to go to Washington and
make him squeal you know continuing the
theme let me tell you something Joanie
if you're planning to cut off the balls
of the Democrats good luck finding
them
well so surprisingly the strategy of so
many Democratic candidates to pretend
that they had never heard of Barack
Obama didn't pay off we had the lowest
voter turnout since 1942 not not you
people I know my studio audience voted
because obviously you guys will wait in
line for
anything but uh but now Obama had to
come out the next day of course and Eed
Crow and talk about the election he said
I love this he said he promised the
Republicans that he would listen more oh
for sake what is he their husband
now he's going to listen
more yeah the the day after the election
he talked nice McConnell and Boehner
they all talk nice about how they're
going to be bipartisan going to work
together that lasted one day the next
day their Republicans were right back to
we're going to repeal healthc care we're
going to block amnesty we're going
investigate Obama exactly what you've
been doing for the last four years you
know when you Republicans say you're the
party of Reagan it's not supposed to be
the part where he had Alzheimer's
you
know and I tell you what's so
frustrating for liberals is that
everywhere where there were specific
issues on the ballots like minimum wage
like gun control all these things that
liberals wanted they won overwhelmingly
and then the people voted for the very
Representatives who are going to block
them they voted to legalize pot in
Washington DC which gives me a great
idea for Michelle Obama's
Garden
I but yes pot had a very good day Oregon
and Alaska welcome to the party Oregon
and Alaska past legal pot it is four
states now four states now have legal
pot pot by the way marijuana was also on
the ballot here in California uh well it
was on my ballot I spilled some when I
was voting